dozens of celebrities media outlets in
the u.s. been walled they could face
legal action over their treatment of the
teenager involved in a confrontation
with the Native American man if you've
been following this story
Nick salmon drew global condemnation
after a video went viral appearing to
show him mocking the indigenous elder
his lawyers say that the youngster has
been slandered though and his actions
misrepresented disturbing viral video
has sparked outrage toward Covington
Catholic High School
a disturbing viral video shows a mob of
teens and make America great again hats
harassing a Native American elder in
Washington named these kids I want names
shame them if you think these is wooden
ducks you in a heartbeat think again
I blame lead poisoning and bad parenting
and oh yeah I blame that kid what a
little
[Music]
the red matter hat is the new white hood
the teenager at the center of the
controversy says his family have even
been receiving death threats now let's
despite the fact that subsequent videos
including one release by his lawyers
show events in a different light and
reveal that he didn't initiate the
confrontation apparently students from
Kentucky's all-boy Covington Catholic
High School were instructed to meet on
the stairs of the Lincoln Memorial to
await their bus home a few yards away
were five black men who identified as
Hebrew Israelites after nearly an hour
of enduring the verbal attack the boys
asked the chaperone if they could
perform one of their pep rally chants to
drown out the hate group the chant
attracted the attention of a group of
Native Americans led by veteran activist
nathan phillips they began to celebrate
by chanting and dancing to the beat
mr. Phillips began moving to his right
down a line of boys eventually stopping
face to face with Nick Sandman the young
man remained where he had already been
standing placing his undivided attention
on mr. Phillips so legal analyst
Jennifer Britton told us that
celebrities generally like those laying
into the make America great again
cap teenage you were talking about their
need to be more cautious for making
inflammatory public statements I think
this is case is gonna be definitely
landmark I mean there's certainly
foundation to go to trial for this and a
lot of Americans can realize that some
celebrities are taking this way too far
they're using their celebrity platforms
to speak out against things that they
really have no expertise or knowledge on
now that being said celebrities should
be held to a certain standard when
making statements because they have so
many followers and it's so damages
reputations
the media has journalistic integrity and
has to do due diligence it has to ensure
that the stories that they publish are
factual are based on context that
they've gotten full information that
they've talked to two or three people
but this rush to judgment all shows that
that is that there is a bias that is so
quick to rush to judgment against Donald
Trump or his supporters that that it's
now harming people and damaging their
reputations and it's really putting a
scrutinizing eye on things and it's
making in the media less and less
plausible
you